und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Anne Gellinek
quietscht ab und zu weil die Kurve so
scharf ist so beschrieb ein wie immer
Grund gelassener Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz gestern Abend den wochenlangen
Streit um das heizungsgesetz in der
Ampel aber alle Seiten hätten ja
schließlich ein bisschen Recht in der
vergangenen Woche haben alle Seiten
zumindest etwas leiser gestritten ob es
zu einem gemeinsamen
heizungsaustauschgesetz vor der
Sommerpause kommt ist weiter unklar
intensiv geredet wurde aber schon
Christian von Rechenberg darüber wie
scharf die Kurve noch ist und warum es
quietscht
eine große Liebe war es ja nie zwischen
den ampelparteien die Bruchlinien im
heizungsstreit sichtbarer den je und
doch die Fronten bröckeln nun scheint
die FDP die Blockade aufzugeben das
Gebäude Energiegesetz sondern auch in
den Bundestag ja weil die Menschen einen
Anspruch darauf haben dass wir uns nicht
über Talkshows unterhalten sondern dass
wir es gründlich beraten meine Prognose
ist dass wir im Herbst spätestens sowohl
die wärmewende also die wärmepläne für
die Kommunen verabschiedet haben als
auch dass darauf aufsetzende Gebäude
Energiegesetz und auch die Union die der
Debatte bisher eine gallige Begleitmusik
spendierte über Robert habe als
heizspion spottete scheint den Ton zu
ändern
sollte er jetzt tatsächlich ein Einsehen
haben Fristen verändern technologieoffen
das ganze gestalten dann wäre das ein
gutes Zeichen für die Bürger aber wir
wollen jetzt auch erstmal das Ergebnis
der Gespräche sehen Habeck der
getriebener von der Causa reichen von
Freund und Feind er bietet weitere
Kompromisse an will später in den
Heizungstausch starten mehr Technologie
zulassen vor allem in Punkte Holz die
fernwärmepläne der Kommunen einbinden
und mehr Rücksicht nehmen auf Härtefälle
eine Basis sie kommt später
aber wir haben noch gerade rechtzeitig
die Kurve gekriegt aber es quietscht ab
und zu weil die Kurve so scharf ist und
an dieser Stelle merken wir es besonders
das Quietschen hat auch mit ihm zu tun
sagen Beobachter einer der Krisen und
Zielkonflikte einladend diskutiert
eigene Zweifel offen zum Markt beträgt
überraschte in der heizungsdebatte das
ist diesmal nicht Erfolg ist also eine
sehr große kommunikative Panne das
müsste man im Nachhinein noch mal klären
woher das kommt also das ist nicht nein
ich weiß es nicht ich kann mir nur
erklären es ist eine Form von
Erschöpfung andere sind das nicht die
FDP gibt die Opposition im eigenen Laden
stellt sich gegen das Gebäude
Energiegesetz ertzt blockiert riskiert
die Stabilität der Regierung
aber es war mit Ansage denn wenn
Parteitage anstehen und auch auf den
Parteitag ist ein exklusives Klima zu
erwarten ist dann werden Parteien in der
Regel unruhig und um dort eine Trophäe
vorzuzeigen gab es diese Intervention
von Lindner ungewöhnlich aber unterm
Strich für den Experten noch immer ein
legitimes Ringen um Lösungen für
Probleme die es so noch nie gab und noch
nie in so einer Regierungskonstellation
das mag aus der Perspektive eines
Politprofis gut und schön sein die
Bevölkerung aber sieht die Sache anders
sie hat Angst sie mag einen Grund dazu
haben nach dem wochenlangen hin und her
insgesamt kann man schon sagen dass
jetzt eine Überforderung also das Gefühl
der Überforderung weil jetzt allmählich
die größte der Aufgabe sichtbar wird wir
haben das selber Jahrzehnte vor uns
hergeschoben die Größe der Aufgabe das
eine Pandemie und kriegt das andere es
wird in der Summe einfach zu viel für
Arm und Reich
also an all diese besonders betroffenen
Gruppen hätte man sehr gezielt auch
kommunizieren können und auch man
versucht ja jetzt so Schritt für Schritt
die Folgen auch aufzufangen und das kann
sicherlich noch viel besser werden und
vielleicht treten der Debatte nun auch
leisere Töne gut von allen Seiten so
dass am Ende eines an sich sehr
demokratischen Prozesses noch etwas
Demokratie übrig bleibt
der schrille Streit zwischen den
ampelparteien über das heizungsgesetz
ist eine Steilvorlage für die Opposition
und da besonders für die AFD sie bekommt
in verschiedenen Meinungsumfragen von
diesem Wochenende bundesweit mal 17 mal
18 mal 19% Zustimmung und hat teils
sogar mit der SPD gleichgezogen sobald
die Umfragen draußen waren fingen Union
und ampelparteien an sich gegenseitig
für den Erfolg der AFD verantwortlich zu
machen wir sprechen gleich darüber mit
dem CDU-Vorsitzenden Friedrich Merz aber
zunächst Nicole Diekmann über den
Höhenflug einer Partei deren Programm es
ist dagegen zu sein
der Kanzler gestern Abend in Hamburg zu
Gast bei der Zeit gleich zu Beginn muss
der Regierungschef auf die Fragen
antworten die momentan so viele bewegen
warum ist die AFD so erfolgreich und was
will er dagegen tun
wir leben in einer Zeit der Umbrüche bei
der ganz viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
unseren Ländern nicht so sicher sind ob
die Zukunft auf ihrer Seite ist ob sie
eine haben aber wenn wir tapfer ein
Problem nach dem anderen lösen und die
Zukunftsfrage und die respektsfrage
nicht vergessen dann wird schon gelingen
was Scholz da herunterspielt ist nicht
weniger als ein Höhenflug seit Monaten
fährt die AFD Rekorde ein diese Woche im
ARD Deutschland trennt zieht sie sogar
gleich mit der SPD Scholz SPD das
Erfolgsgeheimnis die Erzählung der AFD
lautet so wir haben
Alleinstellungsmerkmale wir vertreten
die Interessen der Bürger also wir haben
keine Werte geleitete Politik sondern
interessengeleitete Politik wir stellen
uns klar gegen die wirtschaftssanktion
gegen Russland aber auch die zukünftigen
Sanktionen die schon gegen China geplant
sind aber nicht nur die
umpfe nur ehrlich in einer Partei
einzutreten noch dazu in eine die in
Teilen vom Verfassungsschutz als
gesichert rechtsextremistisch eingestuft
wird das ist ein sehr klares Bekenntnis
auch hier bei der Linken sucht man
verzweifelt nach Strategie er hat die
AFD ihr ehemaliges Kraftzentrum den
Osten längst abgezwungen führt viele
Umfragen sogar an in Erfurt ist Bodo
Ramelow zwar noch an der Macht muss bei
der Wahl kommendes Jahr aber zittern und
setzt auf das Prinzip Hoffnung die
Mehrheit der Gesellschaft will wissen
wie sie heizen können die wollen wissen
wie Sie Ihr Strom bezahlen können und
sie wollen wissen wie ist es mit meinem
Arbeitsplatz und da haben wir eigentlich
gute Antworten die AFD wird sich selber
entzaubern weil sie kein Angebot macht
und die Union im Kampf um den
Parteivorsitz war Friedrich Merz für
sich mit der Aussage die AFD zu
halbieren die stand dabei rund 15
Prozent dieser Plan ist also erstmal
gescheitert darüber hinaus gewinnt seine
CDU im Bund im Gegensatz zu SPD derzeit
keine Stimmen hinzu und auch in Sachsen
führt die AFD die Umfragen an dort will
März Parteikollege Michael Kretschmann
nächstes Jahr wiedergewählt werden seine
Strategie afd-themen besetzen harte
Forderungen formulieren wie die nach
einer Verschärfung des Asylrechts im
Zweifel durch Änderung des Grundgesetzes
wir haben eine Sondersituation weil wir
bewusst gewollt und auch richtig so
Menschen aus Kriegsgebieten aus der
Ukraine in einer sehr großen Anzahl eine
Million unterstützen und deswegen müssen
wir hier handeln und nicht warten bis
die Situation nicht mehr
unter Kontrolle ist rechts blinken
hoffen oder klein reden so sieht der
Umgang mit der AFD aus alles beim Alten
also neu sind hingegen die Rekordzahlen
der AFD
und aus Arnsberg ist uns jetzt der
Partei und Fraktionsvorsitzende der CDU
zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr Merz
die AFD also bei 18 Prozent im Bund in
Sachsen und Thüringen bei um die 30
dieser starke AFD zeigt ja auch die
Schwäche der CDU warum bringen sie nicht
durch
zunächst einmal zeigt die Stärke der AFD
die Schwäche der Regierung das ist die
eigentliche Ursache wenn wir eine
handwerklich und politisch gut
arbeitende Regierung hätten dann lege
die AFD nicht bei 18 Prozent und das ist
die eigentliche Ursache über die wir
reden müssen nicht die
Opposition sondern die Regierung hat die
Verantwortung für die Stimmungslage im
Land und diese Regierung nähert die AFD
es ist ja gutes Recht als
Oppositionsführer natürlich die
Regierung zu kritisieren aber nochmal
die CDU profitiert ja im Vergleich viel
weniger von der Unzufriedenheit der
Ampel als die AFD warum glauben die
Leute Ihnen nicht dass Sie die CDU die
demokratische Opposition ist besser kann
erlaube mir den Hinweis dass wir im
letzten Jahr im Januar und im Februar
bei 21 Prozent lagen und jetzt bei 30
und teilweise über 30 das heißt wir sind
seit
geraumer Zeit mit großem Abstand die
führende politische Kraft in diesem Land
mit großem Abstand auch vor der SPD die
den Kanzler stellt war ist dass wir
natürlich intensiv darüber nachdenken
wie wir unseren Vorsprung hier noch
weiter ausbauen können aber wir werden
natürlich auch zurecht oder zu Unrecht
für manches mit in die Verantwortung
genommen was in den früheren Jahren
richtig oder falsch entschieden worden
ist das heißt das ist ein mühsamer
Prozess wir sind jetzt seit anderthalb
Jahren in der Opposition und in dieser
Opposition arbeiten wir an der
Erneuerung der CDU und dass das nicht
schnell geht und nicht über Nacht geht
das war uns klar also Merkel ist schuld
die Ursachen liegen in der Vergangenheit
und Selbstkritik ist unnötig verstehe
sie richtig ich habe das doch gar nicht
gesagt ich habe gesagt selbst
selbstverständlich arbeiten wir daran
und wir sind mit 30 Prozent nicht
zufrieden aber wir sind auf einer
Ausgangsposition die wir ausbauen können
und wollen nur noch mal ich bleibe bei
meiner Einschätzung für den Zustand der
AFD ist nicht die Union verantwortlich
sondern überwiegend ich gebe zu nicht
ausschließlich aber ganz überwiegend die
Regierung und insbesondere die Grünen in
der Regierung die Menschen in
Deutschland sind diese Art der
Bevormundung einfach leid und damit
machen Sie sich jetzt Luft und ich
möchte dass die Union denen eine Stimme
gibt die mittlerweile zur schweigenden
Mehrheit gehören ich finde es
besorgniserregend wenn die Hälfte der
Bevölkerung in Deutschland sich
mittlerweile vorstellen kann diese
Partei zu wählen und das ist dann eine
Aufgabe von allen auch von uns aber bei
weitem nicht nur von uns Ihre Partei die
CDU und sie selber kritisieren ja das
heizungsgesetz sie durchaus zurecht aber
sie benutzen dabei die Sprache des
Boulevards und der AFD also ich habe da
Heiz Hammer gehört energiestasi die
Verengung des meinungskorridors warum
benutzen Sie afd-sprech und machen sie
so salonfähig Frau gillinek wir benutzen
keinen afd-sprech wenn wir in der
Opposition einmal klar sagen dass dies
falsch ist dann ist das kein afd-sprech
und ich bin auch nicht bereit zu
akzeptieren dass wir mit jeder Kritik
sofort in die Nähe der AFD gerückt
werden das ist ja ein nein ich mache mir
nicht jede einzelne Wortmeldung zu eigen
und manchmal wird auch in unseren Reihen
übertrieben aber die Kritik an dieser
Regierung ist dringend notwendig und wir
benutzen dabei einen ordentlichen
Umgangsstil in der Sache klar und
deutlich aber wir sind immer noch am
nächsten Tag gesprächsfähig wir sind in
der Lage mit der Regierung auch
Kompromisse zu machen ich bin beim
Beispiel beim Bürgergeld ist uns das gut
gelungen das haben wir gemeinsam dann
auch beschlossen das könnten wir jetzt
auch beim Gebäude Energiegesetz machen
setzt voraus dass Robert habe ich
tatsächlich so kompromissbereit ist wir
das jetzt angekündigt hat und wenn er
das ist dann steht einem gemeinsamen
Vorgehen hier gar nichts Weg ein Thema
dass die Leute neben dem Heizungstausch
wirklich umtreibt ist die Zuwanderung
wir haben es gerade im Beitrag gehört
der sächsische Ministerpräsident hat
jetzt Leistungskürzungen ins Spiel
gebracht fordert eine Verschärfung der
Asylpolitik und sogar eine
Grundgesetzänderung gehen sie damit ist
das nicht auch das Geschäft der AFD was
sie da befördern
auch da widerspreche ich Ihnen das ist
nicht das Geschäft der AFD sondern wir
müssen über diese Frage sprechen wir
haben einen kommunalgipfel gemacht in
Berlin und haben anders als die
Bundesregierung die Kommunalvertreter
der Städte der Gemeinden aller Parteien
eingeladen und die haben uns sehr klar
und deutlich gesagt was im Lande gerade
los ist wir müssen das Problem lösen und
ich mache mir den Vorschlag von Michael
Kretschmer gern zu eigen der gesagt hat
lass uns doch eine große gemeinsame
Kommission aus Bund Ländern und
Gemeinden bilden und wir suchen
gemeinsam nachtlösungen und wenn wir
hier Lösungen finden dann wird die AFD
auch wieder kleiner aber wenn die Grünen
z.B permanent und penetrant behaupten
wir hätten gar kein Problem im Bund noch
nicht einmal bereit sind über die
Reduzierung der Einwanderung zu sprechen
geschweige denn Entscheidungen zu
treffen dann wird das Problem größer und
mit dem größer werdenden Problem wird
die AFD größer und sie würden auch
mitgehen bei einer Grundgesetzänderung
das kommt auf das Detail an Karin Prien
eine weitere Stellvertreterin von mir im
Parteivorsitz der CDU hat an diesem
Wochenende richtigerweise gesagt das
muss dann am Ende der Debatte stehen am
Ende der Beratungen ich lade die
Regierung ein mit uns zusammen hier nach
Wegen zu suchen und Michael Kretschmer
den Vorschlag gemacht das ist ein guter
Vorschlag eine gemeinsame Kommission
einzurichten wie können wir das Problem
mit der Migration nach Deutschland lösen
wir haben übrigens dazu bereits sehr
konkrete Vorschläge gemacht in den
Deutschen Bundestag eingebracht was die
Migration in den Arbeitsmarkt betrifft
ist von der Koalition bisher alles
abgelehnt worden wir sind offen für
Gespräche auch offen für eine solche
gemeinsame Kraftanstrengung Michael
Kretschmer in Thüringen steht mit dem
Rücken zur Wand denn im Osten könnte die
AFD die CDU als stärkste Kraft ablesen
schon hat die AFD unter der Hand
angeboten sie könnte sich vorstellen
eine CDU Minderheitsregierung zur
tolerieren wie lange steht die
Brandmauer noch zur AFD hermers
vorgelegt danke für die Frage gibt mir
eine Gelegenheit die sie noch mal sehr
klar und sehr deutlich zu sagen solange
ich Parteivorsitzender der Logo bin wird
es keinerlei Zusammenarbeit mit dieser
Partei geben und es gibt niemanden der
mich übertrifft in der klaren Ablehnung
und Abgrenzung zu dieser Partei diese
Partei ist ausländerfeindlich diese
Partei ist an diese mittig wir haben mit
diesen Leuten nichts zu tun und hier
wird es keine Zusammenarbeit geben unter
der Hand über der Hand auf dem Tisch
unter dem Tisch mit mir und uns nicht
sagt der cdu-parteivorsitzende Friedrich
Merz herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch
und einen schönen Abend
und wir machen weiter mit den
Nachrichten von Hanna Zimmermann und die
beginnen mit der zugkatastrophe in
Indien ja nach dem schweren Zugunglück
in Indien gibt es erste Erkenntnisse zur
Unfallursache laut indischen Behörden
führte ein Fehler an einem
elektronischen Signal zu der Katastrophe
ein Expresszug habe dadurch das Gleis
gewechselt und sei in einen Güterzug
gerast ein weiterer Personenzug breite
darauf hin mit mehreren entgleisten
Waggons zusammen mindestens 275 menschen
wurden bei dem Unglück im Bundesstaat
und Discher getötet Hunderte verletzt
die Untersuchungen dauern noch an
hunderttausende Polen haben heute in
Warschau gegen die regierende
nationalkonservative peace-partei
demonstriert dazu aufgerufen hatte der
frühere polnische Regierungschef und
Oppositionsführer Donald TuS Hintergrund
der Prozesse ist auch ein neues
umstrittenes Gesetz das Folgen für die
polnischen Parlamentswahlen im Herbst
haben könnte kritiker befürchten dass es
der Regierung ermöglicht führende
Oppositionspolitiker wegen angeblicher
russlandfreundlichkeit aus der Politik
auszuschließen
laut Russland sind die ukrainischen
Angriffe auf die russische Grenzregion
bielgorod auch in der vergangenen Nacht
fortgesetzt worden zudem habe es in
einem Dorf in der Region heute Kämpfe
gegeben erklärte der Gouverneur von
biergorod mehr als 4000 Menschen seien
in provisorische Unterkünfte gebracht
worden und auch die Ukraine meldet
erneuten Beschuss durch Russland bei
einem Angriff auf einen Wohnviertel nahe
der Stadt nie pro kam demnach ein
zweijähriges Mädchen ums Leben 22
Menschen sein verletzt worden
bei einem Brand in einer
Flüchtlingsunterkunft in Thüringen ist
ein Kind ums Leben gekommen elf Menschen
wurden verletzt
245 Personen darunter viele Kinder
mussten evakuiert worden werden ob es
sich bei dem toten Kind um einen
vermissten neunjährigen aus der Ukraine
handelt ist noch unklar das Feuer war am
frühen Morgen im Wohnbereich der
Flüchtlingsunterkunft aus bislang
ungeklärter Ursache ausgebrochen die
Kriminalpolizei ermittelt
nach den Auseinandersetzungen zwischen
Linksautonomen und der Polizei in
Leipzig hat die Politik heute Bilanz
gezogen Zustimmung zum Vorgehen der
Beamten kam unter anderem von
Innenministerin väser kritik äußerten
hingegen sPD Linke und Grüne in Sachsen
nachdem gestern Abend Demonstranten
Einsatzkräfte attackierten kesselte die
Polizei rund 1.000 Menschen ein und
hielt sie stundenlang fest knapp 30
Personen sein festgenommen worden 50
Beamte wurden laut Polizei verletzt
es ist die wichtigste
Sicherheitskonferenz des Asien
pazifikraums der Shangrila Dialog bei
dem sich rund 600 Militärs
Verteidigungsminister und Experten in
Singapur trafen wobei das mit dem Dialog
nur so mäßig geklappt hat
der neue chinesische
Verteidigungsminister lieschang Fu
lehnte nämlich ein direktes Gespräch mit
seinem amerikanischen Kollegen Lloyd
Austin ab die USA hatten ihn den
chinesischen general auf ihre
Sanktionsliste gesetzt stattdessen
sprachen die beiden rivalisierenden
Großmächte USA und China also
übereinander und das in verschärftem Ton
im deutschen Verteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius blieb nur der Appell den
Konflikt und Taiwan nicht weiter
anzuheizen Thomas Reichert berichtet aus
Singapur
wirkt wie eine Festung die Kämpfe aber
finden hier nicht davor sondern drinnen
statt Chinas Verteidigungsminister
Lieschen Taiwan auf internationaler
Bühne und unverblümt mit einer Invasion
je mehr diese separatistischen
Aktivitäten für die Unabhängigkeit
herans zunehmen desto entschlossener
werden unsere Gegenmaßnahmen sein und
jede ausländische Einmischung wird zum
Scheitern verurteilt sein
Chinas Militär werde da keine Sekunde
zögern am Tag zuvor wäre es in der
Straße von Taiwan in internationalen
Gewässern fast zum Konflikt gekommen ein
amerikanisches Kriegsschiff wird von
einem chinesischen bedrängt es schneidet
dem US-Zerstörer von links kommen den
Weg ab nur knapp 130 Meter fehlen am
Ende zu einer Kollision
kurz zuvor war ein chinesischer Kampfjet
gefährliche Manöver im internationalen
Luftraum vor einem
us-aufklärungsflugzeug geflogen warum
gefährdet Chinas Militär das Leben
seiner und anderer Soldaten wird Chinas
Verteidigungsminister gefragt seine
Antwort gerichtet an die USA
was habt ihr dort zu suchen wir sagen
immer kümmert euch um eure eigenen
Angelegenheiten und passt gut auf auf
eure Leute Marineschiffe und Kampfjets
kaum je zuvor trat ein mächtiger Peking
so scharf und konfrontativ auf ein
Treffen mit den USA lehnte er ab es gab
nur einen kurzen handy-druck beim Dinner
und es klar zu sagen antwortet der
US-Verteidigungsminister wir suchen
nicht den Konflikt oder die
Konfrontation aber wir werden nicht vor
Mobbing oder Zwang zurückschrecken so
sehr lief die USA attackiert so sehr und
Garn der andere Länder der Region sich
China anzuschließen zum gemeinsamen
Nutzen aber die Botschaft verfängt nicht
bei den Nachbarn während China von
Dialog redet sagt das chinesische
Handeln Konfrontation ich frage mich
daher warum gibt es ein so großen
Unterschied zwischen Chinas Worten und
seinen Taten
auch der deutsche Verteidigungsminister
der nach Lee redet wendet sich gegen
dessen Forderung die Regeln der
internationalen Ordnung müssten neu nach
Chinas Vorstellungen geschrieben werden
principles diese Regeln wurden im
Gegensatz zu dem was hier vorhin gesagt
wurde nicht von einigen wenigen
mächtigen gemacht vielmehr würden sie
gerade für die vielen weniger mächtigen
Länder in der ganzen Welt erarbeitet
zum Schutz der internationalen Ordnung
werde Deutschland im kommenden Jahr zwei
Kriegsschiffe in die Region schicken
eins zwei drei jede dritte Frau erfährt
mindestens einmal im Leben Gewalt und
wenn wir ehrlich sind dann kennen wir
alle auch jemanden der Gewalt erlebt hat
oder wir haben davon gehört und nicht
gewusst wie wir uns verhalten sollen
Gewalt ist weder privat noch Frauensache
und sie geschieht überall in allen
Schichten fünf starke Frauen haben jetzt
eine Initiative mit dem Hashtag die
nächste gegründet gegen die Scham gegen
das Verstecken und vor allem gegen das
Schweigen Barbara luke hat ihnen
zugehört
schaut her sagen sie uns seht genau hin
wir stehen im Leben wir sind stark
gebildet aber wir waren auch Opfer
häuslicher Gewalt durch unsere Partner
wir entsprechend nicht dem
vermeintlichen Klischeebild von
Betroffenen häusliche Gewalt aber wir
waren Betroffene und genau deswegen
sehen wir es als unsere Pflicht an die
Stimme zu erheben
ihres Brand bricht ihr Schweigen und
gründet mit vier anderen betroffenen
Frauen eine Initiative jahrelang erlebte
die Kommunikationsmanagerin häusliche
Gewalt durch ihren Ex-Partner bis sie
irgendwann den Absprung schaffte
ist die Angst und die Scham häuslich
Gewalt des sozialstigmatisiert und es
ist auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt für
uns das ist der Grund warum wir an die
Öffentlichkeit treten ein mutiger
Schritt fünf starke Frauen Betroffener
mit steilen Karrieren mit ihrer
Initiative die nächste wollen Sie
endlich mit dem Klischee aufräumen dass
ich häusliche Gewalt vor allem an den
Rändern der Gesellschaft abspielt auch
deshalb wollen sie laut sein und eine
Gesellschaft die solidarisch ist als
ehemalige Betroffene kann ich sagen wir
müssen es schaffen dass nicht die Frauen
die Scham haben sich zu öffnen sondern
das Täter sich schämen wir müssen eine
Täter opferumkehr schaffen denn die
Zahlen sind dramatisch alle 45 Minuten
wird in Deutschland eine Frau körperlich
durch ihren Partner verletzt
Kristina Klemm blickt seit Jahrzehnten
in die Untiefen dieser Fälle sie kennt
die Muster narzisstischer Täter die
perfidenmechanismen einer Gewaltspirale
all das sagt sie passiert mitten in
unserer Gesellschaft ich vertrete Frauen
deren Männer sie geschlagen haben und
das sind das ist der Chefarzt irgendwie
aus der Klinik nebenan das ist der
Vorstandsvorsitzende das ist der
Staatsanwalt oder es ist der
serienst da auf einer Vorabendserie also
es gibt alle in allen gesellschaftlichen
Schichten sind auch diese Täter zu
finden
mit Initiatoren und Aktivistin Stefanie
Knab sieht in häuslicher Gewalt auch ein
strukturelles Problem sie weiß um die
Ängste nach der Flucht keinen Schutzraum
zu finden das in Deutschland etwa jede
zweite Frau in einem Frauenhaus
abgelehnt wird weil so viele Plätze
fehlen ist für sie ein absolutes
Armutszeugnis eine Frau die eine am
Frauenhaus abgelehnt wird hat keinerlei
Möglichkeiten sie muss dann
höchstwahrscheinlich wieder in die
Gewaltbeziehung zurück oder muss sich an
Freundinnen oder Familie wenden aber
auch das ist kein sicherer kein sicheres
Heim denn Täter wissen oft wo
Freundinnen oder Familien leben mit
ihrer Initiative wollen die fünf Frauen
jetzt auch andere Betroffene ermutigen
ihres Brand hat zu eigener Stärke
zurückgefunden ihr Ex-Partner ist
inzwischen rechtskräftig verurteilt
[Musik]
und hier gibt's noch mal Nachrichten vom
Sport und mit Hanna ja zum zweiten Mal
in Folge hat der RB Leipzig den
DFB-Pokal gewonnen gestern mit einem 2:0
gegen Eintracht Frankfurt und das wurde
heute in der Heimat ausgiebig gefeiert
als die Leipziger Mannschaft im Pokal
ihren rund 8000 Fans am eigenen Rathaus
präsentiert hat Trainer Marco Rose schon
einiges hinter sich gestern Abend
Bierdusche bei der Pressekonferenz heute
dann Eintrag ins Goldene Buch der Stadt
für ihn als gebürtigen Leipziger eine
besondere Ehre
am schönsten war der Moment wo so das
erste Mal Leipzig Nord
Leipzig Mitte Delitzsch die Abfahrten
kam und du du wusstest okay du wir
bringen das Ding nach Hause doch der
ausgelassenen Stimmung vorausgegangen
ein Pokalfinale das spät entschieden
wird erst in der 71 Minute überwindeten
Kuku Frankfurts Kevin Trapp so muss
seinen kurz darauf noch einmal nach RB
verteidigt damit seinen Titel auf dem
Weg durch die Stadt heute Tausende auf
den Straßen es ist ein Triumphzug denn
der Festwiese endet auch in diesem Jahr
bleibt der Pokal ein Leipziger
[Applaus]
Iron Man EM in Hamburg
ist im tödlichen Unfall gekommen der
Fahrer eines begleitmotorrad zwar mit
einem Triathleten frontal
zusammengestoßen nach Angaben der
Polizei starb der 70-Jährige
Motorradfahrer noch am Unfallort der
Sportler wurde schwer verletzt das
Rennen wurde trotz des Vorfalls
fortgesetzt der Franzose wo wurde erster
auf Rang vier landete der Kölner Januar
um Fragen der digitalen Welt um
Flüchtlingspolitik und Fußball geht es
unter anderem auch in der nächsten Woche
Ralf panicek mit dem heute-journal
Ausblick
[Musik]
lasst uns über Geld sprechen unter
diesem Motto steht dieses Jahr die
re:publica die Messe für die digitale
Welt will am Montag in Berlin und
natürlich auch im Web seine Pforten
öffnen drei Tage lang soll diskutiert
werden über alles Digitale im
Allgemeinen und über Knete Cash und
Werte im Besonderen
100.000 Teilnehmer werden ab Mittwoch in
Nürnberg erwartet beim 38 Evangelischen
Kirchentag der letzte von vor 4 Jahren
in Dortmund statt auch dieses Mal wird 5
Tage gesungen gefeiert gebetet und
diskutiert neben Bundespräsident
Steinmeier haben viele kritische Geister
ihr Kommen zugesagt
die stark steigende Zahl an Migranten
wird am Donnerstag Thema sein beim
Treffen der EU Innenminister in Brüssel
eine faire Aufteilung der Asylbewerber
auf die EU-Staaten sowie einen besseren
Schutz der Außengrenzen werden schon
lange gefordert eine Einigkeit aber für
ein gemeinsames europäisches Asylsystem
ist nicht in Sicht
siebeneinhalb Kilogramm schwer 73 cm
groß um ihn wird es am Samstag gehen den
Henkelpott das Finale der Fußball
Champions League steht an in Istanbul
Manchester City oder Inter Mailand nur
einer kann ihnen gewinnen das Spiel
leiten wird der polnische Schiedsrichter
Marciniak das sei noch erwähnt und dass
das Spiel zu sehen sein wird live im ZDF
und so wird das Wetter in der nächsten
Woche im Südosten sind die Wolken meist
dicht und es gibt Schauer und Gewitter
regnen kann es auch im Schwarzwald sonst
scheint die Sonne die Höchstwerte liegen
zwischen 19 und 28 Grad an der Nordsee
sind es 16 in den nächsten Tagen bleibt
es mit 17 bis 28 Grad und viel Sonne
sommerlich allerdings breiten sich die
Schauer und Gewitter auch in die Mitte
aus
das war's von uns hier geht's jetzt
weiter mit der schwedischen Krimiserie
Mord im Mittsommer und die nächsten
Nachrichten gibt's gegen 0:25 Uhr heute
Express mit Moritz neues und hier sind
morgen Heinz Wolf und Marietta Slomka
für Sie da schönen Abend tschüss tschüss
[Musik]